[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
honest trailer commentaries for what if
uh i'm here with danielle we're gonna
talk about our thoughts and feelings
about the series as a whole we're gonna
go through the honest trailer frame by
frame it'll take many hours
i'll also show you some deleted scenes
uh take comments and questions from
viewers like you so put those in the
chat and ryan will flag them and then
we'll tease you with next week's honest
trailer that oh i cannot wait for um and
it's not and it's not dune um the plot
twist uh but we will do it i'm so
excited i can't i literally
this is one of the ones where i'm like
this is the best thing they've ever had
yeah so one of the good weeks um this
one however was not uh and i don't want
to be too much of a negative nancy um
god forbid
but this is one of my least favorite
marvel things i think i've seen in a
long time i didn't like this at all
danielle how'd you feel about what if oh
i loved it i loved what if you didn't
i loved what if fight
[Laughter]
so
i just i like
um i am a really big fan of any time a
series is like but what if
uh buffy didn't meet giles at a certain
point or like what if blah blah blah
didn't happen that is such my jam so
this is just like um
so much my jam i guess i i i like the
idea of the what if series i love a lot
of the what if comic books it gives you
a chance to do well the one the one
episode i liked was doctor strange
eating the universe and like it gives
you a chance to do something like really
dark and like a horror one-off like like
treehouse of horror basically for marvel
or it lets you do something ridiculous
uh like um well actually that's a really
cool one where the the fantastic four
don't get their powers but they just
become like ghostbusters they just reed
richards just makes them like cool guns
and they and they zap uh
there's also
there's a really good one where rogue
from x-men gets thor's hammer i really
like the what if yeah yeah i just think
that given how fun and uh also spooky
the the comics can be i thought this was
a lot of what if uh uh what if you
swapped one hero for another hero or at
least it started off that way and it was
really tough for me to get over that and
to overcome the momentum of like yeah i
guess if you put this character in that
costume um
it didn't even feel like a butterfly
effect of like then a would happen that
b would happen and see what happened it
just like here's them kind of doing the
same thing but with a different voice
actor i just thought they squandered the
potential of this series and it bored me
daniel it bore to be fair there was only
one like one or two different voice
actors and we'll talk about that um but
there was only one or two and they were
kind of important um one or two
different voice actors um
yeah i
i am such a simp for that stuff
um i love the what if this but a
different person
um i will watch you
put an actor
in the same movie
in a different costume
a million times in a row
gosh i am such a sym for that yeah if
that does it for you
fine fine um
yeah i i can't believe that they're
making a season two out of this and then
at the end when they're like actually it
all ties together it just felt very
very hodgepodged and also they have to
do this thing because it's animation
because it's only like a half hour we
really got to get it down to basics like
the marvel marvel paint by numbers kit
uh where it's like you do the quip you
uh you move through the exposition in a
certain way it's got a certain tone and
it just when you reduce it to its basics
i think i don't like the mcu i love the
quips
again i'm i'm
so bad in this one oh my god
crush paul rudd's head for the first
time in my life
i am such a joss whedon girl like
i mean whoa
whoa
walk it back walk it back um i am such a
buffy a fan of weed and ease you
speaking of reading these i i do though
have you ever heard me talk
is he standing right behind me oh god
he's standing right behind him
uh that happened
when the watcher said uh that happened
okay that was that's not good 360 and
then moonwalk out of the out of the room
it was terrible i would
there's nothing i want to see more than
you moonwalk by the way
i could for a minute but well that'll be
a different episode
we have to wait until we do another live
stream and yeah like a movie might sound
like a holiday episode like timmy face
um
is that what timmy c tbt timmy t yeah
tvt
timmy oh that's probably copyrighted
okay i'm so sorry
i'm obsessed with that video
i mean i feel like all of that my
specifics will be handled in the honest
trailer because this was just the the
complaints for six minutes but that's
what you pay to see um let's roll the
honest trailer for
what if
oh that's a good what
what diff
they teach you that in uh fancy art
school by the way
from the studio
ryan just for just for seo sake can we
change the australia title to marvel's
what if while we're live yeah sure yeah
i feel like that's why we could put if
you have a chance to put marvel in the
title like this or the commentary or or
whatever for both if that's what's the
match yeah i don't know why marvel's
yeah
okay thank you thank you all right
there's only like two of them left now
anyways comes a series based on silly
comic books like what if iron man fought
king arthur or what if wolverine was a
vampire that dares to imagine something
even more ridiculous
what if mcu writers could try something
new
but not like new new just a slight remix
of some old favorites let's not go too
crazy here
marvel's what
is yeah i was trying to work it in
daniel you had some joke about how it's
like a puff daddy remix um
it's where it's not like um it it's
close enough to what you like that you
like it but then there's like mace will
show up
well not only that would make it better
uh to me
um
mace uh welcome back mace from
he went to find god and he's returned to
rap so let's all welcome him back with
open arms uh but
puff daddy remix is
well some of them are good i'm just
thinking of the godzilla one which take
your nostalgia goggles off is not a good
song it's worse than come with me is
very good how dare you
not a good song
i had a crush on a boy who kept playing
that song over and over again for 24
hours and i was like i did too i was at
summer camp i took my i took my walkman
and i played come with me uh on repeat
as well but not everything that we liked
in your 12 is still good i think i liked
it because i was twelve but that's uh
come with me
and you'll see that p diddy's remixes
kind of sucked
oh but he did that thing where he would
direct videos and like your head was
right here it was amazing yes he was a a
visual genius that's for sure um
let's just do a retrospective of p diddy
videos uh could we change course now all
right i will
keep watching what if
enjoy some wild animated experiments
that stay true to the mcu by having no
real beginning or end no real message to
get behind and every character from the
most hardened warrior to the most
powerful cosmic being speaks like an ai
barfing out chandler being dialogue
i simply afford drama your outfit would
suggest otherwise
uh guys
i'm covered in sharon
do you get pause that's another thing
and granted damn it that's exactly how i
talk
you're better than that danielle um
i get it it's a cartoon i feel like this
was aimed at a younger audience uh than
your usual mcu fair but it was stuff
like uh like steve would die spoiler
alert and like people are sad for a beat
and then they've just moved on like it
didn't seem like i know it's just every
problem with marvel like amplified like
there's no stakes uh everybody's just
quipping all the time uh
it's visually samey and uninteresting
that's just
i'm seeing a lot of people in the
comments are fighting me very very
harshly
i haven't read any of the read
yeah i like lots of other things uh
captain america civil war oh god i'm the
worst oh my gosh
nice
yeah this is uh this was just i don't
know what it was about this one uh it
didn't it maybe it caught me at the
wrong time um but i just feel like it's
again squandered potential to really
experiment and to and to have more fun
or to do just something something
different and i felt like i got uh
more of the same but with um you know
with some pallet swap it's like it's
like when you're
you hit a special button when you're
selecting scorpion and you know you're
your noob cybot all of a sudden or
you're a purple ninja instead of a
instead of a blue ninja like
um
all right let's keep going
not have horror movies in wakanda we
don't need them we have american reality
shows whom does the dynamite
right now you're running at an eight and
i need you to take it down to a four
your team building instincts
yeah yeah yeah yeah tail to ajar
okay i don't sound like that that is so
not true
that happened
the cosmic overlord of the universe
saying oof that happened
i'm sorry that is exactly how i talk
but you wouldn't if you were a magic
space walnut who saw all things from the
beginning of time you wouldn't be like
um exqueeze me
that's not how you would talk
um i couldn't be
less involved
it's just yeah it's the sameness of of
everybody um so anywho uh let's keep
watching
the other extremely powerful comics
character who swore never to intervene
in human affairs that we're meeting this
fall
hi he's a messy [ __ ] who lives for
drama and this jeffrey right-shaped
planetarium will guide you through
alternate timelines like what if england
had a pop culture icon who wasn't a
sociopath what if every franchise was
better without chris pratt what if all
the avengers died and also agent coulson
was a five on the kids chris pratt must
be stopped
look i'm just i'm just gonna gym face
during all of this i get
a hard side yeah the mario garfield one
two punch we're all we're all reeling
from over here this is like when jj
abrams got star wars and star trek in
the span of a couple years like no one
man should have all this power
that's a song that to do because we will
get d platform um
i
so i was super into uh uh pratt when he
was obviously in like parks and rec and
all that stuff and
i'm happy when anyone gets work but
practice garfield and mario is the
wildest thing that ever happened to us
yeah i mean it's not wild it's just so
uninspired but i look let's all withhold
judgment until we hear
uh noted chameleon actor uh chris pratt
completely changed his uh vocal style
and his comedic delivery to play mario
and
italian-american icon with mario i just
thought
i just like hate mondays guys
don't you hate mondays
what mondays
crazy
uh what a world
um save some for the rest of us chris uh
other people gotta eat um
i i too wanted to play lasagna cat but i
guess we'll never know
uh i would love to watch you just house
a tray of lasagna one day
sure yeah it's called sundays am i right
oh we're not in the same room
high fives don't work
oh i guessed right um
i haven't had lasagna in way too long uh
let's fix that well you the inevitable
garfield watch along commentary
we'll have everyone have their own
personal lasagna postmates to lasagna
tomatoes thank you
i don't want to derail too much but i
still have all of the mountain dew left
that's good too you did drop the how
much of a hoarder you were as we were
talking before the show so i'm not
surprised that there's still
a 20-pack of do i think i crushed enough
dude that i didn't feel bad throwing out
you know the four cans left because i
felt like i was drinking battery acid
that's what the water's for
drink you fill up your tub and you drink
that that's survival 101.
yeah do stays good forever because it's
always been bad
um
sorry derail i am the worst that's the
show's four if they wanted to watch on
his trailer they'd watch that one um
this is for the commentary
okay keep playing
and also agent coulson was a five on the
kinsey scale he's a caucasian male
mid-20s with really great hair it's an
accurate description he's gorgeous
hashtag
steve steve steve i heart steve even
while rotting he smells like lavender
what if the universe had it out for
rachel mcadams you know doctor
what's-her-face what if she was the key
to all of this any interest what if
zombies you guys still like zombies
right sort of okay how about this one
what if killmonger the most sympathetic
villain in the entire mcu was just
destined to become evil like no matter
what someone should have killed him in
his career yeah you mean
i even loved this episode you did what i
did oh come on it's it's right there for
you to be like what if killmonger won or
like what if he like pulled things off
or or something like that but it's like
what if killmonger uh you know saved
tony's weird but all right sure um but
then he still became a villain like an
irredeemable like
bad guy
why
i
killmonger was right
first of all let's start there
killmonger was right um he went back to
wakanda and he brought back all of the
ironman stuff and was like i'm gonna
take over wakanda and i'm gonna get the
us to fight um
hashtag imperialism
but you're saying hashtag you're you're
pro-imperialism just getting that
straight because i was it look
the political message of a lot of marvel
stuff is usually very muddled um
although i feel like in this one they
kind of put it in a nutshell in this
episode where he goes
you gotta be part of the system to
change the system
small bureaucratic reform for the win
um so he is the cinema
danielle should stop talking
no i love that i love that uh rhodey in
that episode wore his military uniform
to a illegal black market arms deal
you just gotta dress up as the full
colonel that's just colonel on the road
his patches his awards and yeah the
whole thing
look you are who you are if i show up to
an award ceremony i'm going to be
dressed like a black zooey deschanel and
he shows up to an award ceremony he's
going to wear all of this
otherwise how are they going to know
it's colonel rhodes um
yeah i wish that the second
yeah the second second of his name
i wish they had done that what if is
what if terence howard i mean we make
the joke but that's but
they couldn't even do because it was
taking place during um that timeline
like they had the the incredible hulk
like they could have done it at norton
sound alike and look alike for that that
would have been that would have been
canon right now
um
but yeah this episode where it's like uh
oh what if what if the military took
over tony stark industries
it's like potato potato to me um
and
we can get into whether or not tony
stark is fascist all day long and no one
watching the stream wants us to have
that conversation but i will desperately
have that with you over slack yeah all
right we'll do that um and then this is
where it started really um
annoying me uh that everything was
ending on a cliffhanger and i was like
oh great they're gonna
that that means they're either saving it
for season two or they're doing what
they did in this one which was the last
two episodes were
um like uh like uh i would say a
dawn of justice-esque uh gathering of
the team
together
they got them all in the in the villains
pub from how it should have ended and
was like all right you're a team now
good go fight
just
pacing people pace together yeah
pacing may sink give the people what
they want
what i want is like eight bananas crazy
episodes that we will that they would
never do in a million years and i could
see them making movies out of these
that's the problem
um all right keep going
good what if they made slightly
different castings fine we'll do it your
way what if ultron stole vision and
chopped off thanos arm and ate the
universe and was like
i'm going to eat you too and the watcher
had to be like not on my watch and they
start punching and adventures fly out
and the robots get hit with the shields
okay sorry the watcher punching just
looked wrong to me it looked like like
yoda in revenge of the whatever
is that registered with where yoda's
grappling
where he's where and he's doing like
flippy stuff yeah he wasn't the watcher
was not designed for like brazilian jiu
jitsu unless it or they could have like
had him do all headbutts which would
actually
f you up
it's just
as a woman with a large head
there's a balance issue
like you can't have a head that big and
be like no i'm gonna fight you like no
you haven't like he should be on all
fours with a head that size like he
can't support it standing up there's no
his neck is so small on his head it's so
big it's like an orange and a toothpick
like it's not
it's just hmm i respect
that we have to have him have him do a
thing but yeah it should definitely be
all headbutts or just more like him yeah
crawling on all four crawling like like
like the people from us
i don't know it was it was weird to have
them go to go to the punches um
again
the watchers shouldn't punch
the watchers should not punch um all
right let's keep watching the watcher
good do you like content piggies get
what you came for
come on why are you crying oh right this
is a show for kids i forget that
sometimes
kick back and listen to find out which
of your favorite actors needed to pick
up an extra check during covid don't
play the fool with me fury michael
douglas really then get genuinely choked
up when you realize you're hearing
chadwick boseman do t'challa for the
last time it doesn't feel over and
finally wonder what dave batista did
that caused disney not to even reach out
all right principles but regardless
thrill has a bunch of million dollar
voices emerge from heroes who look like
the characters you pay 10 bucks for at a
town fair because while disney's built
its entire brand on top quality
animation everyone deserves a break now
and then it's been a tough year are we
sure they didn't buy dreamworks too
uh it's gotta be it's gotta be the same
studio that made some dreamworks movie
or something right because they all do
the face
they all do it as someone who only
dreamworks faces
every face i make is the dream space um
yeah like it's it's literally all that
like
uh yeah
a party thor was was especially guilty
of it he was he was made out of
dreamworks base and look i know
animation is is very difficult and time
consuming and very expensive um
but it's disney like if there's any
place that's known for incredible 3d or
2d animation in-house like they have the
studio they have the technology they
have the experience it's them so it's
just i don't know i feel like i feel
like a crotchfield man and i'm sorry
because
i've loved
i feel like the the stuff they've done
on disney plus has been fantastic so far
so i feel like it's the it's the step
down like they threw a a dark world at
me and i wasn't expecting it i didn't
think we'd have to go back
so
it's uh um
it's not my favorite animation in the
world
yeah um
it's very
tumblr
um
yeah like it's very tumblr and that's
fine and that's great but yeah if you're
disney and you have all of this money
and i know like we're all like things
are happening and there's like a whole
ass pandemic
um but also you're disney you can 100
get better animation yeah i mean i'm
sure look i know it's also not a
one-to-one comparison but like they
dropped luca and seoul during a pandemic
um i know they're working that earlier
i'm sure they've been working on this
too for
pre-pandemic i hope
um oh yeah this was announced like years
ago for sure yeah so i don't know um uh
maybe it's uh i hope it's not like cost
cutting uh uh but it's it felt like cost
cutting it felt like they're like no
that kids will watch anything with uh
with animated jeremy renner in it let's
let's give them that
and i will kids love renner
sam
you're still subscribing to his uh his
app the social media app
oh god
i could do the song but i'm not gonna do
that
wait there's a song
oh well yeah no he did a song jeremy
renner i know he's he's got a band right
yeah he's one of those dudes that has a
band yeah i mean we need to do an mcu
battle of the bands because
robert died junior's definitely got a
band
um
chris evans
no probably not no he has a dog he's got
a dog he's a he's a dog and sweater guy
keanu has a
uh keanu has a band called dog star but
he's not the mcu yet um well we'll see
it's coming does ruffle ruffles i feel
like ruffalo like was in an indie band
in the 90s
he definitely would do a band yeah also
i definitely i won't do it but i have
that jeremy renner song memorized please
bless us bless us with a little writer
wow
okay
is it like kind of an eddie better thing
um he does a little bit it's like a song
about a girl that's like oh god she's so
hot she's crazy
my favorite genre of song
she's so hot she's crazy
all right uh let's keep watching i am so
distracting today what's hot right now
the multiverse and after endgame helped
set up the idea of the multiverse and
one division teased the possibilities of
the multiverse and loki explained the
scope of the multiverse and doctor
strange too gives us multiverse madness
what if we'll drive the message of the
multiverse home even further we're all
one of an infinite number of variants
going through the same
our struggle seen only by a voyeuristic
space walnut who could save us from our
fates at any time but won't wow there
had to be an easier way than killing
free will to explain why terence howard
can't play rhodey anymore or whatever he
thinks one times one is two
so if you want to see your final
character
this is very important
he made statues of like his new numbers
oh he did
oh god
yeah i haven't seen the statues oh god
yeah he made like little
little art
statues of his of his new number
oh man i mean if there's ever like a
behind-the-scenes like moment i would
have wanted to see the most it would be
the contract negotiations for iron man 2
with terence howard where he's arguing
with them about what is and isn't a real
number
and he's just pulling out his statues
saying like well this is a three you pay
me bleep million dollars because this is
a bleep well this is definitely an oom
lot sir like i don't know what you're
talking about
uh i hope people know what we're talking
about if not go uh do your own research
um as they say on the internet uh and
look up terence howard math um it'll
take you down a a rabbit hole from which
you might never escape and there are
statues and there are now statues which
i need to go i need to go check on them
uh all right keep playing want to see
your favorite marvel characters and
exciting new stories that stretch the
imagination buy a comic book but if you
want more of the things you already
liked combined with other things you
already liked resulting in something
slightly less than the sum of its parts
well what if there was nothing else to
watch until eternals comes out
wow
look at them stand there can't wait
starring
i only watched multiverse i mean what do
we think about let's do a pre-eternals
watch
uh
discussion
what are you ex
how are you feeling now that it's
certified not fresh
well
so there is some weird stuff about that
because some of it is like people are on
imdb and being like this is gay
and being like downvote down vote down
vote kkk
which is like well that makes me want to
watch it more um
i think that this whole fourth you know
how in sports teams when the dream team
leaves and they're in a rebuilding year
i feel like this is gonna be marvel's
rebuilding here yeah yeah they gotta
they need some uh uh some draft picks or
something i don't know i'm not a good
sports metaphor guy but absolutely not
either i don't know why i pick sports i
only like ones that are fake and
predetermined i don't know why i pick
sports
i will just say that um
uh
look the gayness is is is
not a bad thing in fact it's a plus
because it's like every marvel is so
sexless uh and not that i need to see
full frontal dong hangs on
in my comic book movies but it'd be nice
for a change
do
effing something
somebody needs to have something in one
of these movies
just like
someone act like you have genitals and
you would like to use them yeah they're
all and it doesn't matter who you would
like to use them on right
guys gals non-binary pals the closest we
get
come on yeah it's one division and like
come on
paul the vision is smooth down there uh
changed my mind
he's totally a kendall yeah
completely
um
what do you think visions channels look
like respond in the chat um
yeah i don't think i'm gonna
unfortunately i don't think i'm gonna
like the eternals but i'm gonna go in
with an open mind but i always thought
that it looked boring and um uh
it looks like that might be what's
getting played out but
yeah i'm gonna go in with an open mind
but it's definitely one of those things
where it's like okay there are a million
of you and you have been around for 2000
years and i don't know what this movie
is about oh here come the cgi uh
spaghetti dogs
now we need now we need to spring an
action
i'm angry i'm a cgi guy
the cgi dogs are back we i know we sat
out the holocaust but this time we
really gotta we gotta get uh get our
[ __ ] together
not thanos just the dogs yeah just the
tops
ever all will be explained um no we'll
go in with an open mind um so yeah and
i'm i'm i have uh no concerns f about
all the stuff lined up after that
spider-man i mean come on they're gonna
they're gonna throw everything at the
wall and spider-man something's gonna
stick
i've read too many spoilers i'm so angry
because they're just like they're in my
like feed and i yeah i keep blocking
people but they keep coming up because
everyone's like he checked this out and
i'm like
yeah
you know what hawkeye looks fantastic
hawkeye looks amazing yeah yeah all
right it's gonna be great it'll be fun
they still got some yeah rebuilding
hey oh
the disney property will be just fine
i'm really worried about disney you guys
oh god i hope they're doing okay do a
wellness check on on bob chapic
just like a little bit of a huggle
yeah that'll be fun
all right keep playing i only watch the
multiverse for the articles you captain
america
the cat is the pratt someone please take
this man's driver's license
[Music]
no matter what so dark
it's so dark glove death and robots
halloween three season of the witch
scarlet no hansen
gundam wang
futurama did it asgardian pie
pricario
hentai squid
and this is what happens when you mess
with a mouse robert you have to die
but why
male ducks have corkscrew penises just
putting that out there i now pronounce
you darcy and a duck
how many times have we brought up how
are the ducks gripping oh is it i i lose
track i think this is three should do
this
every time we talk about a ninja turtle
we talk about how the penis is the
entire length of the body of a turtle um
in regards to april o'neil
and our concerns
but yeah i think that's that's uh i
think we can retire the corkscrew penis
let's uh let's let's tie a bow on it on
that corkscrew and just send it off on
its way
yo um so my lasting legacy on honest
trailers is ann twain's
that is my lasting legacy
so we can let the corkscrew penis lift
no no no it's it's it's it's it'll it
gets funnier until it doesn't and i
think i'm done making coarser penis
jokes unless
there's like another duck on screen then
we'll make the course reviews joke again
and they hang dong
all right uh i think we have some
deleted scenes we had a guest editor uh
randy filling in for kevin this week so
i hope they're in uh uh
in good shape let's let's see what we
got for deleted scenes
starring
watch what happens live the right
watchman the centrist the peg oswell
that atwells my walkman forever stranger
wings mystic arts and crafts brag me to
hell
vision board natasha romanott are you
afraid of the stark stillmonger puke
hemsworth
the air alright zone
sideways stories from wayside mcu
american filler story
weary stories to tell with no arc
hard to believe the multiverse has
lasted this long with so many constant
incoming threats space time was being
held together with duct tape and a
prayer this whole time
yep yep true story true story guys um
all right
uh we got a lot of comments and
questions um so
let's see uh
benzy10 says but overall did you guys
enjoy what if because i had a really
great time with this series and it's
compressed storytelling format um that's
kind of echoing a lot of people who are
like spencer what are you talking about
this was the best uh and
that's great um yeah jess marie wrote
i'm completely on the opposite end of
spencer's opinions today i like the
animation style well i'm on an island of
one
danielle liked it the audience liked it
what if what if i was right you were
wrong everything about that
it's fine it's fine it's a look no harm
no foul i will keep watching these
things uh
including season two um i guess i just
had higher expectations uh and and
that's that's really the key to life is
lowering them right
uh you like you liked it right danielle
i loved it i really loved it i really
really enjoyed it yeah
um i think ryan you wrote this when they
brought them all together at the end it
felt like a herald that's a
that's an insider uh improv reference
but not a mod yeah i get them confused
um
uh let's see adam halbert writes the
ending of the thor episode made me give
up on finishing the series since it
really it wasn't really going to be
standalone yeah they're ending
everything on kind of a cliffhanger um
through episode six or seven at that
point it's like okay all right we're
gonna get like a an epilogue again oh
boy we did um a lot of witcher witcher
watcher punching
um let's see uh
so sl asks were these really the best
group of people from the multiverse to
team up uh what about not evil ultron um
[Music]
also another question uh dallas d what
if you could do your own episode of what
if so danielle what's up what character
or or premise would you like have liked
them to take on oh that's a really good
question um
if i was going to do a what if
this is so dumb um if i was gonna do
what if it would definitely be um
what if
chris pratt as garfield was
was an avenger wait was what yeah it was
an adventure because what if chris pratt
is garfield is is the the dark timeline
we live in yes but what if chris pratt
as garfield was an avenger okay
all right so dumb i'm so dumb no no no
that's uh
yeah i think um
i think we could make that happen uh i
think it's actually only a matter of
time before they buy whatever company
owns garfield and
he's playing opposite himself oh it's
just jim davis i think that he owns it
completely oh nice um but there's been
there's a garfield diverse right there's
a
there's the farm those farm animal
friends that he has
u.s acres
a lot about garfield i was super into
garfield as a kid i'm sorry
i had all of the books
more of a heathcliff man myself but i
respect it
yeah uh a good question from zombizzle
are the watchers are the watcher a
species of alien or is there just one
watcher and the other ones aren't the
watcher but other watchers they're other
watchers okay um
is my understanding
everything changes in the comic books
like a million times yes i get it hi
you're here
sorry there's a cat trying to punch me
um in my chest um
yeah uh maya there is uh they're they're
all watchers and they all go around
watching things um
yeah uh owatu is our watcher for what
happens mostly on earth and in this
dimension but my understanding is that
there are a bunch of watchers okay they
they take shifts
um all right uh evan j pretzer ass we'll
wrap up on this uh and speaking of uh
your cat punch uh just for danielle uh
how was your eye i followed the saga of
your injury on twitter
um so makeup is amazing do y'all see how
good that looks yeah it's good um
it's fine um
i probably don't have a concussion i
don't need to go to the emergency room
um yes baby i get it the cats are really
like sand because they hurt mommy's face
so they have been
very super cuddly lately um yeah no no
no i'm thank you evan um for asking no
i'm totally fine um
it's uh uh yeah i don't need to go to
the hospital i might like check in later
to make sure that i'm not gonna like die
or whatever yeah um but yeah i'm totally
it's good it was
there was a second where baby was real
dizzy and i was a little worried that's
not good when you're living alone and
it's like how long is it gonna take
before the cats start to eat me
um that is literally my fear every night
when i go to sleep oh i'm not gonna wake
up and think someone's gonna find my
finger happy
what happens if i slip in the shower
like these are the thoughts i have when
you live alone there you go uh we'll get
you uh uh
one of those things to help if i can't
get up medical alert um or it's like a
button or like a beeper yeah yeah yeah
and like as alert alert
[Laughter]
i've fallen and my cats are eating me
um and yeah and now lon's got his own
ailments going on today and we are lost
our editor this week for yeah we're on
we're on a skeleton crew
trailer team is so wrecked but you know
what we don't need it because next week
we're doing
we got a fastball right down the middle
um
our clue for next week is we are going
to
dial up something that you've never seen
before um
but you uh you'll be glad we did or i'll
be glad we did uh and then we'll resume
our regularly scheduled blockbuster
program
i am so happy right now i can't tell you
how happy i am
i'm gonna go watch that again uh i i
can't wait to share it with you all next
week here in australia's commentaries
thank you danielle for showing up brian
uh randy everybody behind the camera
thank you for filling in uh we're gonna
get through this people we'll make it to
next week
or what if we didn't who knows i
literally have this movie memorized i
have to wake up now yeah all right
thanks everybody see you soon
[Music]
you